I'm about to go to Vegas never move the
tattoo yep the reversals keep coming
from Blac Chyna I'm still on my healing
Journey on Sunday the model who now goes
by her birth name Angela White shared
the process of getting this demonic
tattoo removed from her hip y'all know
that I had this Baphomet tattoo right
it gots to come off you know what I mean
I'm not about to have no mark of the
beast anything like that in the caption
Blac Chyna explains bamfamin's link to
the occult and Satan claiming the
deity's goal is to create and spread
chaos abuse and torment his victims when
I first got
um
the tattoo
that is not what it meant to me you know
what I mean and
regardless of what it is I just don't
want anything negative or demonic on my
body anymore in the clip the reality
star packs up the car for her drive to
Las Vegas with the help of her kiddos
six-year-old dream her daughter with her
ex Rob Kardashian and 10 year old King
Cairo her son with another ex Tyga so
this is going to be a great
great great great experience and
speaking of her exes Blac Chyna is also
getting rid of ink that links her to
them lasering off this Stevenson tattoo
it's Tyga's legal last name plus this
j-tat a tribute to her ex-boyfriend ybn
Almighty Jay what if you have an
unwanted name something like that do a
few seconds
China shows off the removal process up
close and personal and let's just say
ouch
in the captions of her posts Chyna wrote
that she is releasing all negative
energy that is holding her back adding
thank you God for saving me and in the
name of the Holy Ghost last week China
revealed that she was baptized and
reborn in May I'm doing good I'm uh just
feeling blessed right now and ever since
she's been on a journey of finding
herself I'm actually on my way to go get
these fillers dissolved from my cheeks
and from my jawline most recently China
dissolved the fillers in her face
documenting the whole thing on Instagram
I'm just tired of
first of all I'm tired of the look and
it's just not flattering it's just not
what I look like it like totally changed
my face and I'm just I'm ready to get
back to Angela like Blac Chyna like Blac
Chyna's Black China you know what I mean
and I feel like I've outgrown that yeah
and it's just time for like a change and
I just wanna I just want to be good
[Music]
thank you